En 1944,
la France est occupée par l'armée allemande.
Pour l'affronter,
les alliés cherchent, donc, à ouvrir
un front en Europe Occidentale.
À ce moment là il y avait des allemands,
qui étaient gentils.
Ça se passait plutôt bien finalement.
Ça se passait bien mais quand les SS sont arrivés alors là c’était fini après.
Salut, les Épicurieuses et les Épicurieux.
Si je vous dis "Normandie", vous pensez
peut-être au cidre,
aux prairies et au camembert.
Tout cela, évidemment,
ce sont des clichés.
La Normandie regorge de paysages uniques en France,
d'animaux surprenants et de plages chargées d'histoires.
Elles ont été le théâtre du fameux
débarquement, le 6 juin 1944,
dont nous fêterons le 80ᵉ anniversaire en 2024.
Pour nous guider aujourd'hui,
j'ai fait appel à mon ami Bruno Maltor.
Il est déjà sur place.
Le débarquement s'est déroulé ici,
dans la baie de Seine, entre la Bretagne
et le détroit du Pas-de-Calais.
Plus exactement,
entre les ports de Cherbourg,
sur la pointe du Cotentin
et Le Havre, dans l'estuaire de la Seine.
Leur choix se porte sur 5 plages
de la côte normande :
Utah, Gold, Juno, Sword et Omaha.
Ces noms ne figuraient pas
sur les cartes de l'époque.
Ces plages ont été renommées
par les Américains.
Omaha, par exemple, est le nom d'une
petite ville du Nebraska,
ce choix est un pur hasard.
Au moment de baptiser l'opération,
un officier a demandé
à 2 sous-officiers d'où
ils étaient originaires.
L'un d'eux a répondu "Omaha" et c'est
justement sur cette plage que nous attend Bruno.
Hello Jamy, hello à tous.
Oui, je suis sur la plage d'Omaha, actuellement,
et je peux te dire que ça me fait vraiment quelque chose d'être ici.
Regarde.
Il faut imaginer ce qu'il s'est passé ici, le 6 juin 1944.
Une armada de 6 900 navires, 130000 hommes et
20000 véhicules,
s'approche des plages.
C'est "l'Opération Neptune",
le prélude à la bataille de Normandie.
Cette bataille, elle va durer
2 mois, elle va commencer sur les plages
avant d'aller sur les terres
et ça va permettre d'ouvrir la voie
à la libération de l'Europe Occidentale.
Ceci étant dit,
une fois que les soldats alliés
sont arrivés ici,
ils se sont bien rendu compte
qu'ils allaient devoir grimper
ce qui était derrière moi.
Et évidemment, cette tâche,
elle était très périlleuse.
J'ai enfourché mon vélo, Jamy,
direction
la pointe du Hoc par la voie verte
et c'est magnifique.
Même s'ils sont surpris, les
Allemands se sont préparés à cette attaque
avec le fameux mur de l'Atlantique.
Bien qu'ici nous ayons les pieds
dans la Manche.
En 1944,
selon les informations des alliés,
les Allemands ont installé
de puissants canons à la pointe du Hoc.
C'est un lieu stratégique
car il est situé entre Omaha et Utah.
D'ici, en théorie,
les allemands peuvent donc arroser
toute la zone
où les alliés ont prévu de débarquer.
Pour réussir le débarquement,
il faut donc neutraliser
ce poste de défense.
Regardez, partout autour de moi,
sur le plateau, il y a d'immenses trous
que l'on peut voir.
Ce sont en fait les impacts
laissés par des bombardements,
des bombardiers alliés
Dès avril 1944, ils vont chercher à neutraliser les fantassins
et les artilleurs allemands afin de faciliter le débarquement.
Malheureusement, ça ne va pas se passer comme prévu.
Ils ne vont pas être très précis au niveau des tirs et du coup,
les canons
seront quasiment en état intact.
Les Allemands vont retirer
à plus de 1 000 mètres
de la pointe du Hoc
et pour l'anecdote,
les canons vont être remplacés par des canons factices, en bois.
Mais ça,
les 225 rangers, du Lieutenant
Colonel Rudder,
qui débarquent à la pointe du Hoc
au matin du 6 juin, l'ignorent totalement.
Pour eux, la tâche s'annonce
très, très difficile.
Il suffit de regarder où je me situe actuellement
pour comprendre un petit peu le contexte.
Je suis au sommet de la pointe du Hoc, à 30 mètres au-dessus du niveau de la mer.
Les Américains,
une fois qu'ils vont arriver,
ils vont devoir grimper cette falaise.
De différentes façons d'ailleurs, avec des grappins, avec des échelles
et même pour certains avec des poignards.
Ça va leur prendre
une bonne dizaine de minutes,
mais une fois arrivé en haut,
ça ne s'est pas très bien passé pour eux.
Pourquoi ?
Parce qu'en fait, il y avait plus de 100
artilleurs allemands qui les attendaient,
chargés de défendre leur zone.
Leur centre opérationnel, le voici.
C'est le poste d'observation panoramique
et ils permettait aux allemands
d'observer toute la mer.
Et, je peux vous le dire,
c'est du solide, il tient encore debout.
D'ailleurs, ce que je vous propose, c'est
qu'on aille tout de suite à l'intérieur.
Les Allemands appellent ce poste
d'observation :
un regelbauten.
C'est un bunker muni d'ouvertures
qui permettent de surveiller
l'arrivée de l'ennemi, mais aussi de
positionner des hommes armés.
À l'époque, il y en avait plusieurs
sur la pointe du Hoc
qui étaient reliés entre eux
par des galeries souterraines.
Suivez-moi, on va rentrer dans le bunker.
Comme vous pouvez le voir, en arrivant,
il y a des escaliers assez étroits,
il ne faut pas être trop grand, non plus.
Et on va arriver dans un sas.
Il s'agit d'un sas de décontamination
prévu pour parer les éventuelles attaques au gaz.
Donc on a conçu dans chaque bunker
un sas de décontamination de ce type.
Ces bunkers,
ils avaient donc plusieurs fonctions.
Ils étaient conçus
pour éviter les attaques au gaz
ou encore les obus d'ennemis
mais ils servaient aussi, par exemple,
de centre de communication
ou de centre de stockage de munitions.
C'était aussi, tout simplement,
un lieu de vie pour les hommes.
Oui, Jamy,
ici, les hommes vivaient 24h sur 24.
Je suis dans un dortoir qui pouvait accueillir jusqu'à 9 Allemands.
Comme tu peux le voir, il pouvait il y avoir, ici, des lits superposés.
En journée, ils étaient collés contre le mur tandis qu'en soirée
via les chaînes et les crochets,
on pouvait descendre les lits.
En tout cas, une chose est certaine,
c'est quand même pas très grand.
Et dire que tout ça a été fait
sous la contrainte
et construit par les ouvriers français
et les prisonniers de guerre.
Mais au petit matin du 6 juin 1944,
les Allemands n'ont pas le loisir de faire
la grasse matinée dans leurs bunkers.
Ils sont pris au saut du lit
et opposent une résistance farouche
à leurs assaillants.
La bataille ne dure que 20 minutes,
à l'issue desquelles les allemands doivent
rendre les armes.
En s'emparant de cette position,
les Américains découvrent
alors que les canons ont été déménagés.
Une opération qui a, malgré tout, tué ou blessé 135 des 225 rangers
qui ont débarqué ici.
C'est pour ça que la pointe du Hoc
est aujourd'hui un haut lieu de mémoire.
Ici, au sommet du bunker d'observation,
on peut voir un Rangers Monument.
Mais c'est pas sûr qu'on
puisse l'observer encore très longtemps.
Les falaises de Normandie
sont très fragiles
et sont victimes notamment de l'érosion.
Et la pointe du Hoc n'est pas épargnée.
En 2010, le Congrès Américain a débloqué la somme
de 4,8 millionsd'euros
pour renforcer la falaise
et prévenir son érosion.
Tout comme
les cimetières américains de Colleville,
la gestion du site est confiée à
l'American Battle Monuments Commission,
l'organisation américaine
en charge des sites de mémoire.
Pourtant, ces travaux n'ont pas permis
d'éviter l'effondrement d'un pan entier
de l'éperon rocheux, ici, en mai 2022.
Comme tu peux le voir
Jamy, c'est vraiment impressionnant,
les éboulis ont déjà été emportés
par la mer.
Normal, en Normandie,
les falaises de craie sont fragilisées
par les infiltrations d'eau de pluie,
les épisodes de gel et dégel
et bien sûr, par le mouvement des vagues
qui grignote, inexorablement, leurs pieds.
Ces phénomènes sont parfaitement naturels,
mais ils sont aggravés par l'urbanisation
et par le changement climatique.
Les pluies et les tempêtes,
qui sont de plus en plus violentes
depuis quelques années,
font de très gros dégâts.
Les falaises cèdent en moyenne 10 à 15cm de terrain par an sur le littoral.
Tenez, en Seine-Maritime,
le département le plus touché
par les submersions marines,
1 million de mètres cubes de roches
disparaissent chaque année.
En tous cas,
c'est très émouvant de parler des gens
qui ont changé le cours de notre histoire.
Mais tu sais, Jamy, il n'y a pas que
les pierres qui parlent ici en Normandie.
On va partir en ensemble, justement
dans l'Orne, afin
de rencontrer une femme extraordinaire
qui a vécu plein de choses,
dont le débarquement.
Quand on parle
de la Seconde Guerre Mondiale,
on évoque souvent les débarquements
en Normandie,
puis en Provence
et la libération de Paris.
Mais on oublie souvent une autre bataille
tout aussi décisive,
celle de la poche de Falaise-Chambois, dans l'Orne.
2 mois après le débarquement,
les Allemands n'ont pas tous été
délogés de Normandie.
À Falaise-Chambois, un groupe résiste.
Les Alliés encerclent
alors l'armée allemande.
Au total, 250000 hommes s'affrontent
sur seulement quelques kilomètres carrés.
Et bien, c'est justement
sur ce champ de bataille que
nous retrouvons Bruno.
Oui, Jamy, je suis dans les terres entre Argentan et Vimoutiers
et je viens d'arriver plus précisément au Mémorial de Montormel
où je vais rencontrer la fameuse personne, dont je t'ai parlé un peu plus tôt.
Elle s'appelle Danielle et en 1944, ce n'était encore qu'un enfant.
Bonjour Danielle.
Bonjour.
Vous êtes normande ?
Non, parisienne.
Parisienne, ça commence bien.
Je suis née à Paris 14ᵉ.
Mais vous avez quand même grandi
à Falaise ?
Oui, parce que quand je suis née, c'était en 1939,
donc je vais avoir 84 ans, et les enfants
à la déclaration de la guerre,
ils ont été obligés de partir en province.
D'accord.
J'habitais, ça s'appelait la rue Brette,
c'est derrière le château, ça s'appelait les abattoirs
et il y avait des Allemands, là.
Et le père de mon ami d'enfance,
on était ensemble,
il était directeur des abattoirs et nous,
on allait jouer dans les abattoirs.
Et, à ce moment là, il y avait
des Allemands qui étaient gentils,
le matin, ils nous donnaient des œufs
à la coque, du chocolat.
Ça se passait plutôt bien.
Ça se passait bien
mais quand les SS sont arrivés,
alors là, c'était fini, après.
Donc on est parti de Falaise.
On se promenait le long des routes, c'était sympa.
Oui, parce qu'il
y a la vision d'enfant, au final ?
Oui, c'était notre vision,
c'est ma vision à moi que je vous donne
c'est pas la vision des adultes,
qui devaient être morts de trouille.
Mais moi, j'étais comme ça.
Un endroit que je me rappelle,
on était dans un champs
et il y a des Allemands qui sont sortis
d'un bois, d'une haie, quelque chose.
Et, ils ont pris à parti les jeunes
parce que les jeunes leur avaient dit
"vous êtes foutus", enfin voilà.
Ils les ont condamné à être fusillés
et donc ils nous ont obligé,
nous les civils, à regarder.
Et moi, je me rendais pas compte
mais toutes les grandes personnes
étaient mortes de peur.
Et comment ça s'est passé, justement, la libération, ensuite ?
C'était la joie, tout le monde était là,
tout le monde était content.
J'avais même une poupée
qui avait des drapeaux français,
américains, anglais, en chiffon.
Et j'ai mangé mon premier chewing gum, que j'ai avalé !
Et est-ce qu'il y a un message que vous voudriez
transmettre aux jeunes générations ?
Plus jamais ça !
On voit la guerre en Ukraine,
mais vous en avez pas l'odeur,
vous avez pas les bruits, vous avez pas
les cris des gens qui sont là.
Vous savez que, encore maintenant, quand il y a une bête crevée dans un coin
ou autre chose, je le sens,
c'est resté dans ma tête.
Et qu'est-ce qu'on peut trouver
dans ce musée ?
C'est la mémoire,
c'est important pour tout le monde.
Je trouve que c'est important
pour la paix.
Maintenant, c'est mal parti.
Quand on voit à gauche, à droite,
la vie humaine, elle ne vaut pas grand chose, actuellement.
Merci beaucoup Danielle.
Je crois que c'est tout.
C'est déjà pas mal !
Voilà.
Merci beaucoup.
La mémoire.
Entretenir la mémoire pour éviter
de reproduire les erreurs du passé.
Autant que faire se peut.
Allez maintenant, direction la côte.
Cette fois, Bruno se dirige vers Carentan,
une petite ville située
dans le département de la Manche.
On oublie la guerre pour une excursion
sur le chenal de Carentan.
Il s'étire sur 7 kilomètres,
avant de rejoindre la mer.
Déjà arrivé, Bruno ?
Oui, Jamy, je me trouve plus précisément
sur le port de Carentan.
Il y a des superbes bateaux autour de moi,
comme tu peux le voir.
Alors je te rassure, je vais pas aller sur le Dreknor Viking, pour la petite balade
qu'on va faire ensemble, ni sur la barge
qui est la rescapée du débarquement américain.
Mon bateau, c'est celui-là.
Et je vous présente les deux
capitaines, Michel et Samy.
On y va ?
On y va !
Alors notre première étape,
c'est un pont canal assez unique en son genre j’ai l’impression.
Comment ça a été construit ?
Alors, c'est l'ingénieur Charles Lavigne qui l'a mis au point, bien sûr, qui l'a créé.
Il a été créé quand, finalement, ce pont là ?
Bah là, il a été inauguré en 1994,
ça correspondait avec le 50ᵉ anniversaire du débarquement, donc c'était
une grande fête locale.
Bon, en tout cas, Jamy, j'ai pas mal
voyagé autour du monde
et je crois que j'ai jamais vu ça.
Et, si tu le regarde d'en haut,
ce fameux pont canal,
ça ressemble
à une coque de bateau inversée.
Alors, pourquoi ici l'eau passe-t-elle au-dessus de la route et non l'inverse ?
Pour l'harmonie du paysage, bien sûr,
mais surtout
parce que de nombreux voiliers,
qui sont à quai
dans le port de Carentan, empruntent
ce chenal pour rejoindre la mer.
Si l'on avait construit un pont classique
suspendu au-dessus du chenal,
il aurait fallu construire un édifice
très, très haut pour que les mâts
ne heurtent pas le tablier du pont.
Alors qu'avec un pont canal,
on ne se pose plus la question.
Alors j'ai l'impression qu'on enchaîne
les découvertes sur la baie de Carentan
parce qu'on vient d'arriver à une écluse.
C'est ça, c'est l'écluse de Carentan
ou le sas quoi, de mise à niveau.
Et ensuite, on va aller vers le canal
qui va vers la mer.
Et, il paraît aussi qu'il
y a des phoques dans le coin.
Normalement,
il y a des phoques, normalement.
Bon là, Michel,
j'ai l'impression que les paysages,
ils ont bien changé, hein ?
On est à la Baie des Veys, c'est ça ?
C'est ça, on arrive dans la baie des Veys et la mer est forte aujourd'hui
donc du coup,
on pourra pas voir les phoques.
On verra pas les phoques, aujourd'hui.
C'est la nature aussi, hein.
C'est la nature, c'est la nature.
C'est très rare qu'on voit, pas les phoques, mais bon,
voilà, aujourd'hui on les verra pas.
Bah remboursé.
Si vous voulez, il y a pas de problème.
Ils se sont installés dans la Baie des Veys,
il y a un peu plus de 30 ans,
en provenance d'une importante colonie
qui se trouve dans le sud de l'Angleterre.
C'est une espèce côtière
qui aime les eaux froides et tempérées.
On reconnait l'espèce
grâce à sa tête plus large et plus ronde
que celle des phoques gris et au nette
décrochement entre la tête et le museau.
Tenez, avec une paire de jumelles,
on peut aussi observer que ses narines
forment un V.
Jamy, je crois que j'ai trouvé un phoque !
Ou c'est une maison ?
Regarde Jamy, on peut voir tout là-bas, la pointe du Hoc et Utah Beach,
au final, c'est ce que les héros du débarquement
ont pu voir le matin du 6 juin 1944.
C'est ce que je t'ai montré
au début de la vidéo.
Au final,
la boucle est bouclée, à bientôt.
Merci Bruno.
J'espère que cette découverte
de la Normandie vous a plu
et qu'elle vous a permis de mieux
apprécier la richesse historique
et les paysages de cette région.
Si vous avez aimé, n'hésitez pas à liker,
à laisser des commentaires
et à vous abonner à la chaîne,
si ce n'est pas déjà fait.
Avec Bruno, nous vous donnons rendez-vous
très vite, pour de nouvelles découvertes.
Je vous souhaite une excellente semaine
à toutes et à tous
et à dimanche prochain,
pour de nouveaux savoirs Épicurieux.